pretty sure this movie killed brain cell
oh my god this movie
[Music]
replicas so replicas is definitely a
January movie starring Keanu Reeves
Keanu Reeves works in this lab where
they're trying to transfer human
consciousness into a robot's body and
his family dies in a car wreck so he
clones them and transfers their
consciousness into their bodies half of
this movie is about Keanu Reeves cloning
his family and no one's supposed to know
about it the other half of this movie
this company is trying to transfer human
consciousness into a robots body and if
that sounds like two different movies it
feels like two different movies - this
feels like two different episodes of
Fringe the outer limits the x-files
something they were like let's crush it
together and make one movie it'll still
have the budget of a TV show and it will
show when we show the robot but
hopefully Keanu could pull it on course
he can't because this isn't Keanu as we
know him now this is Keanu as we knew
him in the 90s like at a point it was
fun to make fun of Keanu Reeves because
it's like his acting range was blue we
were like Hollywood then at a point it
was like yeah but he's cool then he
makes it work he owns it and that's what
makes him great it's John wick baby and
if he didn't have that he would be neo
forever no this is like Keanu how people
used to make fun of kyon if he was bad
in this movie and I don't even blame him
you just feel like he didn't want to be
there I wonder if the studio was like
hey if you want to do that passion
project you need to do this it happens
it's a dirty part of Hollywood I don't
know for sure but I have to feel like
there was something
iana's career is looking up man we got
John wick three come and you're telling
me he was like no I really need to do
this piece of [ __ ] oh come on someone
had a proverbial gun to his head he had
to do that per a contract I have to
believe that nobody in this movie's good
then one of the characters flips into
some great be villain you're like you're
talking like a great B villain and it
just comes down to the screen ride this
movie is everything bad 90s sci-fi er
maybe bad early 2000 sci-fi loves you
and you hear people say I don't like
sci-fi what they mean is they don't like
bad sci-fi they don't like movies like
this this movie did everything shitty
sci-fi movies do directionless
convoluted plot flat acting horrible
dialogue nothing can stay long enough
for it to marinate to mean anything like
I had a point in this movie Keanu Reeves
it's like I can clone their bodies but I
can't transfer their consciousness so he
just has to figure it out it takes time
for him to figure it out till he's like
oh yeah now I can do it and then he does
it or how about when he's clutching his
dead family's bodies then he gets the
realization like oh wait if I do this I
can
bring back and transfer their
consciousness I had that you wreak a
moment right now because I needed to I
had no choice the difference there is
simple it would save us about 15 minutes
and I could have gotten out of this
movie
15 minutes sooner call me selfish I
would have preferred they went that
route if you're gonna say right now well
that wouldn't make much sense that just
means you haven't seen this movie
nothing in this movie makes sense I
really feel like this is one of those
movies that got shelved you always hear
about that like movies that were written
a couple decades ago then they got
shelved then they just dusted off and
all right we'll make this it's like that
this movie was written in a really dark
time for sci-fi like Hollywood was at
their low is sci-fi they were just
churning out crap and this was one of
the [ __ ] storms someone passed off as a
brainstorm but it was shale and they
dust it off and they were like oh hey
someone wrote a screenplay after Johnny
mnemonic came out I guess we'll make
that now they didn't adjust the original
budget for inflation that 90s dollar
doesn't go as far now is it what of them
again I don't know for sure I don't know
why I keep making up stories as to how
this thing came to be I'm just trying to
find logical reason to the madness as to
how this thing exists and for the life
of me the normal procedures just don't
seem to fill it so it had to have been
contractual blackmail or someone found
this script wedged into the grandma's
vent or like let's make five bucks I
want to talk about bad CGI there's this
robot in the movie it's not good all
right I'm gonna spoil something I'm
spoiler warning don't watch this movie
anyway
this spoiler should mean jack [ __ ] to
you the end game had Keanu Reeves
transferring his consciousness into a
robot body so there could be two key
honorees now but when that robot kicks
in the door he's like get away from my
family but he sounds like Gianni was a
kid away from my family I don't know why
I was like how do you sound like him
your consciousness doesn't dictate what
your vocal chords sound like your vocal
chords do and it's not just the voice
just the robot scene in general just it
was nail in the coffin for this thing
and I guess it's on the [ __ ] poster so
I guess it's not a spoiler
oh god that CGI robot was terrible
though like I thought Hollywood was at a
point where it's like if we can't make
robots look RIS semi-realistic
we're just not gonna try someone was
like I'll show you like if this movie
wanted to be a movie about Keanu Reeves
transferring human consciousness into a
robot I'd be fine if it wanted to be a
movie about an organization that wanted
to do that and they're gonna backstab
Keanu Reeves fine if this movie was just
about Keanu Reeves cloning his family
then things start going wrong fine if
this movie wanted to be a movie about
someone who clones his dead family but
he could
clone three of the four of them so he
erased their memories and they start to
remember and then things start going bad
because of that fine but it wants to be
all that [ __ ] in a bum rush job no it
doesn't work it's just really sloppy but
it's left open for a sequels not kidding
a sequel come on it can't get his sequel
if this movie gets a sequel before I get
the concluding chapter two legacy of
kain I'm out [ __ ] it [ __ ] this place I'm
going to Mars
Ilana are you a fan take me the [ __ ] to
Mars if this [ __ ] gets a sequel yeah
studio
whoever made this you can quote me on
that put that on the blu-ray box this
movie truly is a January movie this
movie truly is dog [ __ ] it's like
everything has the makings work could
have been interesting but this movie
missed the mark on all of it it's truly
talented to miss the mark on everything
that much he would think in terms of
probability something would have hit the
mark but now it's like c-3po yes I got
no look at that missed it every time but
every one of those everything was a
whiff ISO replicas have you seen this
movie that's probably a rejected episode
or two of a sci-fi show why did you
think about it or what's the shittiest
sci-fi movie post-90s
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you